oh no do you hear that
you know whenever they start playing
that song it's not going to end well so
i just finished mike flanagan's latest
netflix horror midnight mass and now i
need to explain to my mom why there's a
bunch of used tissues next to my
computer i think this might help me in
this video but my dad grandfather and
great grandfather were all ministers so
please show them i made the right career
choice by hitting that like and
subscribe button because in this video
there's a ton to unpack like why do some
people resurrect and others do not is
the angel actually an angel and what
happened to it i'll also be pinpointing
some cool easter eggs like did you catch
this shot of the jew bear home jhuber
was the villain in mike plan against
gerald's game based on the book by
stephen king and yes we are going to be
diving into some pretty heavy subject
matter breaking down flanagan's
interpretation of what heaven god and
the afterlife really is because let's be
real the first time i listened to
aaron's speech i nearly spontaneously
combusted it's a lot to take in so grab
a couple glasses of communion wine and
indulge in the body of christ because
we're about to embark on a wild ride the
final episode is titled revelation in
fact every episode is named after a book
in the bible revelation is fitting not
only because it's the final book but
that it depicts the rapture or end of
the world and that's exactly what the
inhabitants of crockett island are
facing we open on saint patrick's
catholic church on easter sunday this is
a quite interesting patron saint as he
is known as the patron saint of carrying
the cross and banishing both serpents
and demons as you can see this easter
service has gone about as well as the
time i brought my ex-girlfriend back to
meet my parents what occurred here is
nothing more than a midnight mass occur
a botched event that was supposed to see
god's new covenant for the world a
covenant which would see bloodthirsty
vampires take over as the dominant
species on earth a world where there is
no more death god still has a plan
and death isn't part of it
anymore
not for all of us but father paul the
church's leader hides a terrible secret
that's not his name at all the big
reveal in episode 3 is that father paul
is the 80 year old monsignor john pruitt
who supposedly fell ill while visiting
the holy land also i think this is
director mike flanagan in a brief cameo
sorry mike that's not you a
semi-dementia ridden pruitt which for
those of you who are curious the name
pruitt means brave little one got lost
while on the road to damascus and
stumbled into the desert a sandstorm
forced him to seek refuge in an ancient
ruin which he describes as being a
church however whether it's a church for
god or something else isn't entirely
confirmed there he uncovers what he
calls an angel an angel who attacks him
feeds off him then miraculously brings
paul back to life and de-aging him about
40 plus years now i don't know about you
guys but i never remember reading about
bloodsucking angels in sunday school to
keep this miracle a secret pruitt
decides to lock the angel in a trunk and
travel back to crockett island posing as
the fictitious father paul paul is a
fitting name for him since that was the
name saul took when he went on the road
to damascus and he later became one of
jesus's apostles like saul pruitt became
paul for reasons of clarity for the rest
of the video i'll be referring to him as
paul since that's what he's called for
the majority of his screen time paul
ends up locking the angel in a trunk and
bringing him to the island never explain
how he's able to get the angel into the
trunk especially considering how strong
we'll see the angel is but it's entirely
possible the angel wanted to be taken
from his confines in the ruins and as
we'll see throughout the series paul and
the angels seem to have an understanding
with one another with the angel
successfully on crockett island it's
only a matter of time before some
strange things occur dozens of dead cats
wash ashore after a storm these cats
were actually killed by the angel who
paul has let out at night to feed their
bodies have washed ashore after a brutal
storm there are even brief moments
scattered throughout the early episodes
where characters hear the angel land on
their rooftops but then a miracles start
to happen the first one with
wheelchair-bound lisa who's suddenly
able to walk lisa was accidentally shot
by town drunk joe collier paralyzing her
from the waist down but the miracles
keep on coming mildred an elderly woman
suffering from alzheimer's becomes
younger and her disease disappears other
characters de-age as well take a look at
this comparison of annie flynn here from
the first to last episode her eyesight
has gotten better and her husband ed's
back no longer has pain allowing him to
dance with her for the first time in
ages this sudden uptick in miracles has
been what resident bible thumper beverly
keane calls a full-blown religious
revival it seems like everything is
going well on crockett but as we'll soon
find out all good things must come to an
end these quote-unquote miracles are the
result of the angel blood which father
paul has been secretly putting into the
communion wine this is why some
characters never experience a miracle or
resurrect after being killed they never
partake in communion like riley or joe
collier and for those wondering yes we
will get into riley in a bit in episode
6 most of the town has joined the church
for midnight mass even the sheriff's son
who was a devout muslim has seemingly
converted because he believes the
miracles to be of the christian god
which as the sheriff states earlier in
the season is silly because muslims jews
and christians all share the same god
they just refer to him or her by
different names allah yahweh god paul
along with a few others who know his
secret of actually being father pruitt
intend to lock off the island so they
can transform all the believers into
these vampiric beings ones that can
never die paul believes many things
first that these miracles can only come
from god so by giving people these
miracles he's doing god's work second he
believes that god's will can change we
see how god's will has changed from the
old testament to jesus's covenant also
known as the new testament and now we
have a third covenant what's happening
on this island tonight is the birth of
god's new vision for the world just like
he had a new vision for it with the
creation of adam and eve and a newer one
with the birth of christ he calls on his
congregation to be the first soldiers in
god's army to create a world where there
are no borders or flags where we are all
one so
it is a war
and there will be casualties
and we must be soldiers there's just one
caveat in order to become this immortal
being you have to make a sacrifice you
have to die
the final transformation will not be
yours unless you let your earthly body
die so that your divine body can awaken
i guess father paul forgot suicide as a
sin in the catholic religion but again
that just points to my theory that the
angel isn't an angel at all i want to
briefly describe how this angel blood
process works because it can get
confusing on who has powers who doesn't
and why some people resurrect and others
do not angel blood is the key to
everything when father pruitt is
attacked by the angel the angel gives to
him his blood in return this allows him
to heal at a rapid rate but paul hasn't
gone through the final transformation
yet death he didn't die in those ruins
his death doesn't happen until the end
of episode 3. this is why he's able to
attend the church potluck and the sun
while later on he'll die if the sun's
rays touch him you see the one weakness
of both the angel and the vampires is
that they burn in sunlight what allows
one to resurrect from a death is the
angel's blood the same blood he's been
spiking the communion wine with so those
who didn't partake in communion will die
for good if they are killed those who've
been coming to church taking communion
they have nothing to fear tonight
as for the rest of them
let god sort them out but even if you
haven't received the blood through
communion there is another way to
resurrect such is the case of howard
hobbs whose sturge fed off and then gave
him his own blood so he could resurrect
this resulted in poor howard killing his
wife and children when he awoke in a
state of bloodlust but because they
didn't have the angel blood in them and
he didn't know about giving them blood
they died for good speaking of blood
sarah gunning the town doctor finds that
some of her patients blood samples burst
into flames while in sunlight so she
does some of her own research in episode
6 she discovers a blood disorder called
erythropoietic protoporphyria or epp for
short a disorder which causes its
infected to become anemic and
photosensitive anemia just means a
deficiency in red blood cells which is
why we see father paul collapse a bunch
and why he needs blood to sustain
himself blood is high in iron which is
used to create the protein hemoglobin
found in those red blood cells sarah
suggests that this epp or at least
something like it has been given to the
townsfolk it could even have been what
caused aaron's baby to disappear in her
womb causing the body to basically
destroy it so now aaron has a personal
vendetta against father paul for killing
the thing that she said saved her life
aaron ran away from crockett at the age
of 16. she had an abusive mother and
wound up marrying a man just like her
mom a drunk and abuser so when she found
out she was pregnant she ran back to
crockett she wasn't going to go through
the hell of raising a child with a man
who espoused the same characteristics of
her evil mother she says this pregnancy
saved her life
she saved me
and now she's just gone and aaron's
story gets at the core of one of
midnight mass's main themes what is our
purpose why do things happen the way
they do cause and effect and there is no
better character that encapsulates this
than riley flynn riley was a rich guy in
the startup business who one night in an
alcoholic stupor gets in a car crash and
kills an innocent young girl tara beth
by the way the actress who voices the
judge in the scene here is none other
than flanagan fave carla gagino riley
ends up spending the next four years in
jail and moves back with his family on
crockett where he tells aaron his life
is meaningless because he has no purpose
no money no prospects i just
i just exist that's it i have
absolutely no purpose at all but that's
where riley is wrong everything and
everyone has a purpose he just hasn't
realized this yet god can
take that pain
and turn it into something good
something with purpose if riley never
killed that poor girl he never would
have made it back to crockett if he
never made it back to crockett he never
would have been killed by the angel and
turned into a vampire just like father
paul and if he never turned into a
vampire he'd never sacrifice himself
burning up in front of aaron prompting
her to destroy the religious vampires
thus saving the world oh that's a lot to
take in this all points back to aaron's
story if she was never pregnant she too
would have never made it back to
crockett it points at some master hand
guiding these characters along which
leads to some of the more weightier
themes of the season in the final
episode all of erin's choices have led
her to the moment where she burns down
the rec center the final place of refuge
for the vampires to hide before the sun
rises the vampires idiotically have gone
and burned the entire town down in an
attempt to kill the non-believers
beverly equating it to the fourth bowl
of revelation in which the world is
consumed by fire the fourth angel poured
his bowl upon the sun and it was allowed
to scorch men with fire this would be
their downfall as aaron and the sheriff
burn the rec center leaving nowhere for
them to hide from the sunlight the angel
ends up attacking aaron and feeding off
her blood but what the angel doesn't
realize is that aaron is cutting holes
through its wings severely limiting its
ability to fly we saw earlier in the
episode that while the angel feeds it's
almost impossible to break him out of
his bloodlust lisa even shoots it while
feeding it and it barely acknowledges
her but as aaron slowly dies we get this
contemplative monologue from her through
voiceover which tackles such heavy
questions as what is god where do we go
when we die and what is heaven let's try
to tackle these one by one what is
heaven in traditional christian theology
heaven is a place where the souls of the
good live for eternity but for aaron
there is no heaven and there is no hell
heaven and hell are what we make them on
earth and that's what we mean when we
say heaven
no
mansions no rivers of diamonds or fluffy
clouds or angel wings
you are loved
and you aren't alone
that is god
that is heaven but what does that mean
if we die where do we go quite simply we
go back to earth as dust to feed the
great cosmos in a never-ending cycle of
life and death to be repeated over and
over again aaron remember you are dust
and to dust you shall return it's
fitting that the final shot of the
series is of the dust of the townsfolk
literally falling back to earth riley
understood this this is why his letter
to paul after he dies reads remember you
are dust and to dust you shall return it
flies in the face of paul's belief of
the afterlife so if we're all just dust
then what is life aaron equates our
fleeting moment here on earth as a dream
life is a dream aaron says we never
remember our dreams thus when we die we
won't remember our time here we are
merely in an infinite cycle of life and
death birth and rebirth strung together
by infinite dreams and that's
what we're talking about when we say god
the cosmos
and its infinite dreams we are the
cosmos dreaming of itself
it's simply a dream that i think is my
life we always forget our dreams and we
will forget our lives but it will repeat
again dreams play an important part in
the series perhaps for none more so than
riley who tells aaron in his dream he
can never see past the horizon this is
because he never makes it past this
moment he burns into flames for him his
dream ends here paul even says in
episode 4 about life maybe it is a dream
but if it is
we're all having it in the final episode
paul turns his back on what he believed
was god's plan and exclaims that he was
wrong he has seen the town's people turn
into ravenous bloodsuckers and the
violence and pain it has caused this is
why when he catches his daughter dousing
the church in gasoline he helps her
years ago father paul had an affair with
mildred and they had sarah but they kept
this a secret this is why sarah talks
about how paul always strangely looks at
her it's not because she's a lesbian and
he looks down on her it's because he's a
father who has to live with the hell of
watching his daughter grow up without
being her father sturge one of the
devout followers shoots sarah as she
plans to light the church on fire and
paul goes to her side giving her his
blood so that she may live but sarah
denies it she would rather die than turn
into a vampire paul's arc ends when he
himself burns the church choosing to die
alongside his two loves mildred and his
daughter ali and the sheriff worked
their way to the beach to pray in the
traditional muslim fashion facing mecca
ali has turned back to islam after
witnessing the horror of what his new
religion has brought bev arguably the
most evil of all the characters awaits
her death for a person who so strongly
wants to make it to heaven she sure
doesn't want to go even clawing away at
the sand making any statement a few
hours earlier extra fitting we all say
there's a heaven
then we claw
fight and beg
for a few more minutes at the end and as
all the vampires await their death by
sunrise we get one of the final themes
of the series forgiveness forgiveness is
something many of the characters yearn
for joe collier is forgiven by lisa but
also needs to learn to forgive himself
father paul asks mildred for her
forgiveness sturge so longing for
forgiveness from anyone for the evil he
has committed asks ukr and finally
there's riley a man so wrought up in the
guilt of killing an innocent girl he
can't forgive himself nor ask for
forgiveness from the girl he killed
since she's dead that is until his final
moment as riley dies we see him on the
boat with tara beth and she extends her
hand to him in a moment i interpret as
forgiveness the two hold hands and it's
hauntingly beautiful the only remaining
survivors of crockett island that we
know of are lisa and warren who have
made it off the island there's also the
angel that haphazardly attempts to make
it to the mainland with its clipped
wings which is ironic since aaron the
girl who cut his wings tells a story
about how her mother made her hold
pigeons as a child while she cut their
wings mainland is 30 miles from the
island and it is assumed that the angel
would not have been able to make it
before the sun rises however we never
actually see it die the final line does
offer some clues lisa who was infused
with angel blood giving her the ability
to walk again tells warren i can't feel
my legs this could mean that the angel
blood in her body has simply dissipated
or because it coincides exactly with the
sunrise that the angel has died causing
all the quote-unquote miracles to
reverse either way midnight mass ends in
tragedy almost everyone has died but i
can't help but see a glimmer of hope
here a lot of the characters saw the
error of their ways the angel and
vampires were stopped and it gave me
hope that there will always be people
who will stand up against religious
zealotry but what did you think of
midnight mass i literally finished the
entire season in one day and have had no
one to talk to about it so i want to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much